ça m'a clairement c'est clara morgane
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
ga
on va maintenant jouer à la bataille et
glacé vous êtes il ya quelques mois je
l'avais déjà acheté vous êtes également
novembre à écouter on va voir tout de
suite ce qui se passe en novembre pour
vous alors là dessus aujourd'hui je sais
pas la mieux vous avez déjà regardé oui
évidemment abba tension novembre
attention c'est pour vous cette photo
c'est pas la mieux en fait il faut il
faut avoir l'idée quoi hein c'est
chef voilà et là c'est le 15 et donc
nous est neil combien 3 le 3 monbadon
lundi 3 vous êtes vous n'êtes ni juste
eh bah oui ça ne s'invente pas car à
morgane je boirai tout le dit si tu ne
vas pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
[Musique]
holy lola
le maire de caracas
merci c'est n'importe quoi attention au
canada pense qu'effectivement moi je
suis fan de toi en tout cas je trouve
que tu es un amant câble il assure de
l'émission ça il est comme ça fait
plaisir
la côté est folle à traiter jambières il
a pris sa tête de beau gosse mais grave
au tapis alors continuer ça lui a jamais
fait les grands plans sont jean michel
maire ça fait du bien je trouve qu'il
fait un truc incroyable c'est qu'il est
digne en toute circonstance ils seront
dans les rues sur une situation
totalement improbable est toujours là
dink pardon j'ai qu'est-ce que je te
dire je veux m'excuser ben je mixe comme
chez moi et et je trouve ça incroyable
je retombe toujours sur ses pieds et je
trouve que tu es si la rémission
on va parler du coffret i'm so excited
qu'on aime beaucoup ici dans l'émission
de notre coup de coeur la semaine
dernière merci j'adore ville comme ça
jusqu'à la fin quand elle parle elle
fait des petits chocolats jeter rolex
c'est clair avec ce qui se passe alors
c'est une nouvelle façon de parler qui
limite très bien mais si munich
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]